et on va en discuter avec Sébastien et
Gérald Sébastien je vais commencer avec
vous parce que c'est assez inhabituel
une sortie comme ça d'entreprise qui
s'en prend à Philippe Couillard mais
est-ce que vraiment Pétrolia pense
qu'elle peut faire changer d'idée
Philippe Couillard je pense pas que
Pétrolia pense que elle peut faire
changer d'idée Philippe Couillard parce
que son idée est déjà bien arrêée mais
le mérite qu' a eu la sortie de Pétrolia
aujourd'hui c'est de nous montrer
l'autre côté de la médaille évidemment
on est ici dans une bataille de
l'opinion publique et Alexandre Gagnon
le Pétrolia a très bien joué son rôle
c'estàdire qu'il a parlé des aspects
légaux il y a un contrat à respecter des
aspects économiques il y a des revenus
en jeu aussi mais je pense pas que
Philippe Couillard va changer d'avis sur
Anticosti alors partant de là il y a de
la pression quand même qui est mise sur
le gouvernement je me demande si
pétroliia est pas en train de préparer
une éventuelle entente à l'amiable avec
dédommagement pour sortir du contrat ou
encore une poursuite devant les
tribunaux avec dédommagement aussi pour
compenser pour les pertes de revenus ce
qui amène une question géralde est-ce
que Pétrolia a les rein assez solid pour
affronter comme ça le gouvernement ben
ce serait difficile parce que des
sociétés comme cellees-là ce sont des
petites sociétés d'exploration il y en a
dans les mines il y en a dans les métaux
dans l'énergie il y en a dans le secteur
biopharmaceutique ce sont des
entreprises qui font beaucoup de
recherche dans l'espoir de trouver le
gros lot justement un endroit où on va
pouvoir véritablement s'enrichir ça
prend du capital patient ça prend du
capital de risque ça prend souvent un
bon soutien gouvernemental juste pour
vous dire depuis le début de l'année
2015 pétrolier a perdu 855000 ll perte
net pour les 9 premiers mois de 2015 et
son action ce soir ne vaut que 22 cent
et évidemment on se le demande tous
est-ce qu'il y a du pétrole Anticosti
est-ce que ça peut être rentable
vraiment alors on est quand même en
terrain hostile on sait que ça va coûter
une fortune aller chercher le pétrole
d'Anticosti c'est tout un défi le prix
du pétrole est à 30 dollars c'est
certain qu'à court et moyen terme ce ne
serait certainement pas rentable ensuite
la technologie de la fracturation
hydraulique demeure une technologie qui
est controversée qui est contestée mais
qui est quand même même encore très
utilisé particulièrement aux États-Unis
en Pennsylvanie et maintenant faut
savoir qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans le sol
d'Anticosti les experts s'avancent à
dire qu'il y a un certain potentiel
d'autres en doute alors on est vraiment
dans un terrain difficile à exploiter a
tout ce contexte là mais est-ce que ça
met pas aussi en relief Sébastien un peu
les contradictions du discours de
Philippe Couillard parce qu'il a un
discours sur Anticosti ça reste flou sur
les autres projets pétroliers oui comme
le pipeline d'énergie est au Québec
comme l'extraction du pétrole en
Gaspésie ou encore le gisement Old Harry
qui est à cheval à terneuve et au Québec
en effet le fil conducteur c'est
toujours le pétrole évidemment monsieur
couard va jouer sur les nuances en
disant que Anticosti c'est un milieu
naturel qu' y a de la fracturation
hydraulique que les autres extractions
de pétrole ce serait pas nécessairement
par facturation par la méthode plus
traditionnelle mais des fois dans les
nuances on se perd un peu dans le
message et les gens vont dire tant qu'à
prendre un virage vert prenons-le le
virage vert et faisons une croix sur
tout le pétrole alors par souci de
cohérence monsieur Couillard va devoir
prendre des décisions et clarifier ses
positions sur les autres projets
pétroliers au Québec alors en attendant
cette décision de Monsieur Couillard
merci beaucoup à vous deux de vos
lumières toujours à plaisirci